[Music]
if you're an adult in dc or united
states you probably have a credit score
and you've probably been told maybe more
than once to live your life in such a
way that will improve that strange
number that lies somewhere between 300
and 850. build good credit if you're
told and financial success will follow
the higher your credit score the happier
and more secure you will be
that is not a wholly irrational belief
credit scores have a pervasive though
often invisible set of impacts on our
lives they are everywhere today they're
often required for renting an apartment
for getting a mortgage for taking out a
loan even for getting a job but for a
number so important it can be remarkably
arbitrary you've probably experienced
just how capricious and downright weird
your credit score can be pay off a loan
do the responsible thing and your credit
score may go
down not up but maintain multiple credit
cards use them frequently and
continually pay installment loans your
credit score is likely to
increase as long as you never miss a
payment
it is a very strange system now believe
it or not it wasn't always like this
this peculiar practice where a score is
so powerful in determining so many
aspects of your life wasn't always
around in fact credit scores also known
as fico scores after the company that
created them weren't used to determine
loan pricing until
1989.
that's not that long ago
how did it get this way how did we come
to a point where this funny little
number exerts so much power over our
daily lives
to understand we'll have to go back a
bit to a time called the 1970s it was
the age of bell-bottom jeans and disco
gerald ford god bless him and dog day
afternoon dog day afternoon not just al
pacino but john cazale and charles
dirting
but the 1970s was also a time when
american industry was getting rapidly
automated and outsourced and a lot of
people who had previously made a pretty
good living began to lose out throughout
the 70s and going into the 80s 90s and
the aughts industries like steel
production or auto manufacturing rapidly
shed their workers and places like
youngstown or flint or warren ohio
that's my dad's hometown we're left
without a whole lot of support
manufacturing fell from more than 30
percent of total employment in 1955 down
to 22
1975 and then less than 19 percent by
1985. by 2005 it had fallen to just
barely above
10
of the total jobs in this country for
the most part these high-wage industrial
jobs with good pensions and benefits
were replaced by jobs in the growing
service sector
a lot of people in our great national
industrial belt wound up working at
places like walmart or mcdonald's which
provided no benefits or pension and
wages a lot lower than what people were
previously making at the same time as
this process of de-industrialization was
unfolding a new philosophy was on the
rise in government
it was an attitude that prioritized belt
tightening
austerity deregulation an approach that
was called
neo-liberalism
as many unemployed or underemployed
workers grew into a surplus population
on the margins of the economy political
elites slashed welfare programs while
deregulating the industries like banking
and in 1978 the supreme court prevented
states from enforcing laws capping
interest rates for nationally chartered
banks gutting anti-usury protections for
lenders so
the 1970s saw two important trends first
de-industrialization and falling living
standards in much of the united states
and second the deregulation of banking
and lending in the 1980s these two
trends would collide you see with the
new glut of households that were
dependent on low wage no benefit jobs
people could no longer survive just on
their incomes as they might have been
able to before so they had to turn to
the exciting new world of consumer
credit and debt became a bigger and
bigger part of working-class life
this led to what the scholar suzanne
soderbergh calls
debt fair
consumer debt as a substitute for good
jobs and good wages and a social safety
net now of course debt has been around
for a very long time and was already
widely used in the united states to
finance big ticket purchases like cars
or college
but as wages collapsed and welfare
programs were cut
more and more families were forced to go
deeply into debt just to stay afloat
the cold hard reality was that people
just couldn't live on what they earned
and were constantly on a treadmill of
debt in order to provide for their
families
in the 1980s banks learned how to take
advantage of this situation before the
credit cards they offered were a loss
leader for them
but then they realized something
important the way to make money was not
to target people who were well off and
could pay off their debt no it was to
target people who are not well off who
were reliant on debt and who could not
pay it all off at once as one banker
said in an interview and i quote
it didn't require a lot of investigation
to see that the people who paid their
debt in full every month were not
profitable banks called these customers
revolvers
people who took on the maximal amount of
debt they could without defaulting and
who could be charged higher interest
rates as a result
overwhelmingly of course these revolvers
were living paycheck to paycheck
who needed debt in order to get by in
the harsh new economy they became the
target really the prey for an explosion
in consumer lending with the plastic
credit card at its center the banks
pitched it as a matter of freedom and
flexibility but for the downwardly
mobile people who were targeted it was
about necessity
the massive expansion of consumer
lending is where the credit score came
in see lenders had long employed ways to
discern how creditworthy their
applicants were with arbitrary judgments
of whether they were
shifty or
of good character
but as corporations amassed huge reams
of information on customers and their
behavior they now had enough
computerized information for them to
cook up algorithms about who was and who
was not credit worthy so in 1975 the
first fico score was developed
but the banks weren't so interested in
trustworthy or creditworthy lenders no
they wanted those revolvers the people
who would make them as much money as
possible and when the first general
purpose fico score came out in 1989
that's what it was designed around which
is why in 1995 the director of consumer
policy at experian one of the biggest
credit rating agencies admitted
modeling just credit risk is passe the
real risk is that a customer is not
profitable
they were searching for what one banking
publication called
debt prone consumers and systematically
targeting working class people who now
needed debt in order to survive and who
could be charged higher and higher
interest rates as a result so starting
in the 1980s lending to the poor
so-called subprime or non-prime lending
grew rapidly
the riskier the borrowers were the more
interest they could be charged and the
more money the bank could make off them
that's why at wells fargo one of the
biggest banks in america loan officers
were incentivized for years to
aggressively market subprime loans to
black communities even for people who
qualified for prime loans at lower
interest rates these victims were the
profitable customers the banks were
looking for wells fargo called these
ghetto loans and loan officers referred
to the individuals they were trapping in
debt as
mud people
the goal of course was never to help
them it was to make
money off them through predatory lending
the credit score became a crucial part
of this it's a tool of discipline that
makes you into the ideal customer for
the banks that's why credit scores don't
reflect actual financial health things
like the difference between your income
and your spending or how much money
you've saved what they do reflect is you
being a reliable
juicy profit source for them they're not
looking for trustworthy borrowers
they're looking for people who can be
counted on to live in debt because
keeping you in debt means profit your
credit score rewards you not for making
decisions that actually help you
financially but for taking on the
maximum amount of debt that you can
possibly repay
in an economy as unequal and predatory
as ours credit scores may be necessary
in the narrow sense of what our system
demands
but credit scores and the entire system
of debt that lies underneath them are
not a fact of nature they're not
something eternal like the thespian
artistry of al pacino credit scores are
necessary only in an economy that
cannibalizes the hard work sweat and
tears of its working people that
regulate so much of our lives through a
number reflecting your utility to the
banking industry you can spend your
whole life working on that number and
many of you will
but no matter how high you get that
score no matter how many years of work
and sacrifice you spend
you will have already paid the price
i'm chase madar wandering law professor
for the grivel institute
[Music]
[Music]
you